6 11 it's a monday morning you know so
much of our valley's history is lit up
right the glittering lights of las vegas
they linger on forever at the neon
museum downtown and now it has another
big addition and the addition is bianca
holman who was on display right now all
morning long at the dm museum with the
new edition bianca i see your lights
have been turned on as well
oh yes you know i glow from within you
know my light is everywhere i go
thanks john
we're standing in front of the planet
hollywood sign that has been
dismembered and dissembled and traveled
down las vegas boulevard and is now here
at the neon museum so aaron berger is
here to tell us more about this massive
structure and just how y'all got it down
here good morning thank you so much this
is really amazing so we have four major
pieces of the globe each one weighs
about 1300 pounds in the center of that
you have a 12 thousand pound structure
that supports everything
it is made of fiberglass neon
incandescent lights it is just such an
iconic piece we're thrilled to have it
as part of our collection and so it was
it was donated kind of tell us you know
how it ended up here i know you all had
to you were telling me you had to shut
down the boulevard to get it down here
that is just incredible it really was so
planet hollywood is so generous not only
did they donate the sign to us but they
also provided the transportation and in
order to do it we had to do it in the
middle of the night so we could have
multiple lanes of traffic and and be
able to bring this
monster to our collection we're so
excited i mean you don't realize how big
things are until you're up close
underneath of it and you see all the
different parts so an incredible sight
to see and coming up in the next half
hour we're definitely going to share
more about what's next for this piece of
las vegas history back to you guys in
the studio all right thanks so much
beyond